Palais coffin which arrived here in the
night amid flares and flags and fans
just cheering him on really as he came
home here to Santos the pitch where he
played all of his Club football at the
peak of his career to be laid in the
center circle and as you've just seen he
is lying almost in States the lid was
taken off the coffin it's an open casket
and all the fans who've been queuing
outside many of them all night will be
allowed to file past the coffin and pay
their last respects and and say goodbye
to the man they call Viva or Ray long
live the king the king of Brazil the
king of football and certainly the king
of Santos the place where he made his
home from the age of 15 he came here as
a 15 year old and he was brought by his
father donino who's also a footballer
and they signed him and he and he played
his first match at 15 and scored a goal
and they said at the time this guy will
be the greatest footballer in the world
now they they didn't know it was just
like
hyperbole Brazilian exaggeration but it
turned out to be such a true prophecy
and here we are at the very end of his
journey back in Santos he'll be laid to
rest tomorrow but he will stay as I said
almost in state on the pitch for 24
hours so the fans can come in pay their
respects at lots of dignitaries as well
lots of politicians the head of
Brazilian football the head of world
football Gianni Infantino of FIFA has
confirmed he will attend we're not sure
if the current Brazilian Stars will come
it's it's quite chaotic here and quite
chaotic very chaotic here as it often is
in Brazil it's it's not like a very
serious official funeral that you would
expect to see in the UK it's not like
that at all and you can probably hear
the bossa nova music and the samba music
playing behind me they're playing the
the anthems of Santos football club so
there is a sort of feeling of a
celebration of of his life as well
although it is a somber occasion but um
yeah as soon as we see the people who
start to file in the famous people to
start to fall in and there will be
plenty uh we'll bring that to you but
incredible to think that he is lying
down there in an open casket I didn't
think they it's it's culturally what
they do in Brazil but I didn't think
they would do that given that he has
been so ill but that's what's happened
and we'll bring you the latest
throughout the day here from The Villa
belmera stadium in Santos